der dreher doch spaß das team war cool
ich fühle mich herzlich kommt sondern
bedeute ich hab's ja in den letzten
videos schon angekündigt heute heute
kommt ein neues interview wir haben wir
die möglichkeit heute mit einem hilft
mir darsteller in territorien und zwar
ist das der tournee den vierziger das
größte ich du hast in einer folge
mitgespielt wie hieß der asse könig
hatte könig und ja wir sind irgendwie in
kontakt gekommen haben uns irgendwie so
mal getroffen ich bin gerade berlin -
gerade in berlin
und ja ich würde sagen dann stelle ich
am anfang einfach kurz vor wir wissen
was machst du ja also ich bin denn ich
komme aus berlin und bin jetzt bekannter
auch bewahren müssen durch die erfolge
der as i könig er war ein bisschen sehr
hardcore auf jeden fall wären wir gleich
noch mehr zu hören
und das habe ich auch viele sachen
hinter gemacht schon vorm fernsehen und
bin wirklich fernsehen gekommen und
jetzt
und du machst ungerecht und musik habe
ich mir schon verlinkt heute könnt ihr
gerne mal abstecken
und ich würde sicher wenn die rally bis
dann reden wir nicht lange drum rum und
fragen wer in die fragen dick bin bereit
ok alles klar
schon wegen erst vollkommen von cloud
girl 2003 wie fandest du deine
hauptrolle in hilft mir persönlich ich
fand sie so an sich als mir das drehbuch
geschickt wurde habe es mir durchgelesen
und fans schon relativ witzig rechnung
ich mache auch normalerweise nur sachen
die ich auch sehr witzig finde und dann
sowas geht schon sehr an die grenze des
zuschauers auf oder es hat mir irgendwie
es lustig und ich habe bock drauf und ja
also ich kann schon witzig also jetzt
hat auch spaß gemacht
ok also du wirst du bist du bist nicht
mehr du bist auch so locker hat hinter
den kulissen gerade leute
er ist auf jeden fall so ist
ehrlicherweise sage ich schäme mich als
übertrieben für diese sachen also ich
stehe dazu er hat das gemacht 20 kaputt
zu machen
interessant dazu so die folge kam er
gerade erst online sofort im monat oder
so laut ist das für uns gehört die du
auch gesehen hast kann auch gleich
darauf eingehen wann wurde das gerät vor
drei jahren dreieinhalb jahren also
lange ja was die für nachkommen
erst raus von dem monate verzweigungen
kampf im fernsehen oder vor einem monat
bei youtube
und ja das war s woche seine ersten
sachen die ich mit text fürs fernsehen
gedreht haben war dann halt direkt für
das ist manchmal noch genau sagt man wie
fandest du endlich meine nächsten drauf
super ich bin ganz ehrlich hat es
gefallen ich konnte mich also komplett
anguckt ist ganz witzig megawatt haben
ich habe ich den soundtrack connector
der ist cool drauf reagiert sogar bei
ich ich denke mir mal so was ich also
einerseits ist es halt so in meine
sendung ist ja an sich schon so voll
aber anders als man vielleicht auch
nicht wieso die die leute wissen ja so
mitmachen aber farfan zwar an du hast
auch gemacht also sehr respektvoll habe
ich null irgendwie angegriffen gefühlt
oder so das wäre ganz cool fand selber
hat sich auch franz media entertainment
hast du lachen
verstehe ich auch selber denken bestimmt
auch noch eine frage auf jeden fall dann
greifen die frage erst mal vorneweg
leute haben auch viele von euch gestellt
ist diese behaarung esri also ich jetzt
gerade ich hab mich rasiert das leben
einiger zeit und das gerät eingeschoben
aber die waren echt was war nicht
angegeben er habe ihr kommentar gelesen
denke dass angeklebt ja was nicht wahr
es war auch gar nicht viele denken ich
wurde angefragt nur ringen hahn oder so
das war das als krasser daran habe ich
angefangen
wir hatten kein kein foto von mein
körper mit haben deshalb nur wir drehen
hier sehen ich bin sehr oft oberkörper
frei und habe noch gefragt soll ich mich
rasieren weil ich bin müssen wir haben
extra was gesagt und vorne rein
die meisten etwas doch jetzt mal hast du
willst und da hab ich gesagt okay da
kann ich mich halt nicht und jetzt in
der folge auf jeden fall dass die haare
wir haben zwei kumpels von von da hinter
der kamera zwischen ben bell 811 fragt
wird man für das was man spielt auch
genug bezahlt also ohne dass konkrete
zahlen zu nennen
was war sodann empfinden faire vergütung
ist ganz okay ich habe jetzt nicht wir
nun wohl nie bekommen oder
und das war schon für die drei drehtage
glaube ich landes insgesamt war die
bezahlung rechte komplett also als auch
06 ketsch genommen ist auch hat mega
spaß gemacht beides hat gepasst kassiert
hat okay kommt immer mal machen so
entspannt wie cross lisa ganz viele
zahlen frage was schwer eine asoziale
rolle zu spielen
bist du an deine grenzen gekommen da
wird gerade die jungs waren schon mal
sagen so viel geschauspielert hat er
nicht dabei was sagst du dazu
es war das war klar auch übertrieben
also ist klar wir haben es immer ein
bisschen übertrieben aber es war auch
schon gut authentisch aber ich bin auch
so ich bin darauf relativ harmlos
unterwegs und das liegt also für mich
war das eine mehr keine rolle
ich bin ich jetzt extremer wenn die
grenzen kommen einfach mal so mal so mal
den us open hat jeder hat da sie in sich
und ich auch nichts mehr versendet und
ich habe einfach ausgelassen richtig
nochmal auf 200% basis und das war ich
erinnere mich versuchen die 110 zu
diktatur ist eine szene wo du deiner
mutter wie bier darüber geben was aber
so war doch so denkt man sich selber
manchmal ist es schon ja herr wie man
selber natürlich nicht machen dafür die
folge war es vertrieben
trotzdem ist das natürlich okay ihre
fragen sie 22 franken eine sache die wir
schon beantworten hass und zwar lachst
du darüber
ja ja ich bin aber auch gar nicht so
dass ich sage ich habe mich jetzt dafür
ich bin wirklich mega auf ich kann über
mich selber lachen
ich denke ich wuchs mit freund manchmal
selber anwender am nächsten ist das ist
schon witzig nur ja nicht also ich komme
die kommentare feier ist aber noch
mehrfach auf mega lustig wo sich alle
sagen ihre dinger ich lachte die niesig
hdf fragt was machst du jetzt beruflich
ich mache also die wieder fürs fernsehen
auch für andere formate die man auch
kennen das ist ja im fernsehen und
kalkulation was sagen wo man sich wohl
nicht noch sehr bei den tag und nacht
sind nämlich oft gehabt hab ich oft
aufgetaucht habe warum auch und auch rtl
sachen auf streife und meine geschichte
also die trächtige sachen und probiert
ob es ihn mehr richtung dass ich hab
auch werbesports umgedreht für
verschiedene anbieter 12 werbespot noch
mehr das fuß zu fassen
ok arbeiten noch nebenberuflich aber ich
probiere das untersuchen okay vielleicht
fuß zu fassen
also schauspiel schwerpunkt aber macht
auch noch einmal sorgen genau wenn du
kommst jetzt hat dieser mann ist jetzt
gerade in der korona zeitalter auch
nicht nachhelfen müssen klar und
deswegen ihren job aber für stück ja
schon cool hauptberuf auch erkennen dich
leute auf der straße manchmal durch hilf
mir wurde tatsächlich auf arbeitnehmer
so undercover zu bleiben aufarbeiten
dass ich meinen job zu machen aber ich
habe einen vertrag an soll es auch
niemals erwartet hätten sie erst vor
einer woche sogar erst haben sie so ist
geheim hielt
das video von hatten wir ja sagen hat
ich brauche also eine online show aktiv
auf youtube und jahrelang mal zu gast
haben schon öfter kann ja auch schon
ich hatte überall aber müssen
viele wie läuft das ab egal sowie ist
dass wir erkennen dich leute wenn diese
von hilfen wie läuft das ab
sie schauen sie sich einfach nur an und
den castor irgendwo ja genau das was
fängt oft so aber nicht kennen dich doch
irgendwoher und sagt ja nicht ich bin
der jetzt von der folge so und dann
irgendwann kommt sagt warte mal auf
youtube war hast doch der und darunter
irgendwann kommt man zum thema haben
so also kommen sich direkt mit der sie
könig oder so
so ist es bis jetzt und ich aber die
sagen ständig irgendwoher youtube
gesehen da habe ich überlege schon es
könnte schon das sein und dann kommt ja
aber es ist schon eher so dass die leute
eher so mal kucken wat den kenn ich
irgendwie ja ja und dann eher so die die
sich zutrauen dich anzusprechen
doch daran dass cook auch manchmal leute
ans herz dass mein team zu erwischen
das kenne ich auch bei youtube sind ja
auch die gucken einfach machen da nix
trauen sie haben keinen bock jemand
anzuquatschen akkord aber auch mal leute
natürlich sagen hey du bist ja auch in
einer scheidung muss man sagen ich bin
schon nicht kleinen leute und der winkel
ist jetzt auch ein bisschen anders
ja ich bin da ich bin so 190 euro 1 6 x
ja also ist ein stabiler typ auf jeden
fall kann man nichts sagen - fragt auch
noch was hast du dir gedacht als du die
folge das erste mal gesehen hat ich
wusste ja ungefähr ist gedreht habe ich
bin schon gespannt auf die ausstrahlung
kamen nach drei jahren herzlich sagt er
später
und dann habe ich mir angucken kumpel
denkt er auch mitspielt dann sieht das
war ein echter freund von mir ist
gebucht werden wir den als ablenkung
geben aber das war ein privatauto
privaten freund dazu da stehen halt
geholt name ist sozusagen angucken ich
habe mich irgendwann komplett weg
bestimmt ist mit ablöst und sehr weg
gefeiert
aber das heißt jetzt erst gesehen als
sie auf den zug kam genau also gerade
nicht im fernsehen gar nicht gesehen
nachher nochmal gucken anguckt kann
selbst ein teil kurz mal gesehen aber
nicht
christoph buck emo raven fragt wurdest
du in der öffentlichkeit schon einmal
bloß gestellt also manchmal tatsächlich
gesagt hat so harder oder so also wieder
ich bin da so ein typ der da wirklich
mega also darüber steht ja auch voll
voll mit selbstironie und so richtig
bloßgestellt jetzt licht das ist jetzt
mich dass mich jetzt extrem schlimm
gehört habe ist bisher noch liegt auch
an der körpergröße und müssen sich auch
kennen das ja ja ja das ist ein bisschen
zu hoffen ist ok er muss jetzt
vielleicht seien keine ahnung war
deshalb fragt kanntest du hilft mir wenn
ja wie kam es dazu dass leute gemacht
hast ich kannte hilfen der chauffeur
hatte informatik länger gibt ja bekannt
auch schon öfter diese schlimmen folgen
es gibt daher diese ganzen mit diesem
fleisch als die anfrage bekommen habe es
war so dass ich auf install vaskuläre
ich habe ich so gerade ein kart ein
einschreiben lassen verschiedene tv
formate er hat mich da ein schreiben
lassen und habe nach einer knapp einer
woche glaube ich fünf tagen oder so
schon ein anruf bekommt für die folge
haben hauptrolle für dich nach fünf
tagen nach dürfte also nicht mal eine
woche als auswärtiger daran die gerade
position von der staffel und dachten ja
er würde vielleicht passen keineswegs
ich mach mit handy oder alles hat
gepasst
und ja ich kann da hilft mir schon
vorher ausgedacht mit genauso hab ich
überlegt ich will jetzt hier nicht so
was machen irgendwie einen baum liebe
oder live sex habe ich habe gedacht dass
sowas kommt dann kann man genau das
geschafft mir egal
das ist ein super hat gepasst das witzig
kann man machen
lukas luzifer fragt was genau bereust du
übrigens gar nicht so dass ich sage ich
möchte diese klagen und hab mich hier so
angriffen ja nicht das gibt es nämlich
auch noch dieses gesicht gesehen dass
leute wollen von der blonde der
eigentlich so genau
es hat alles gepasst ich habe gar kein
negatives feedback an die
an die leute der dreh hat doch spaß das
team war kult ich fühle mich dann null
wie angegriffen
tatsächlich wäre das auch eine geile
einstellungen wie viel geld müsste man
den zahlen damit dass wir nochmal
beihilfen damit machst budget passt auch
genau so viel einfacher das genauso aber
jetzt natürlich schon mal drin was sich
reputation dass wir das hinbekommen ja
aufheben also ich würde eine fortsetzung
ja sie kleider dabei auf jeden fall habe
ich endlich mal für eine rolle angefragt
er wirklich oder
die beiden jäger das hört was wenn ich
weiß ich bin ich bin mir nie ganz sicher
ob die wissen dass ich so wenigstens mal
aber wenn ihr das seht leute dann ladet
mich ein ich hoffe nicht unbedingt die
jüngste entscheidung andere sache ich
mag manchmal spaßeshalber das so also
das motto wer ist die jugend heute
verzweifelt so die beiden darstellt ich
bisher kennengelernt habe haben
eigentlich über sich selbst gesagt ja
das motto der serie war ich eigentlich
als ich diese rolle bekommen naja hat es
auf dich ja auch zugetroffen geht also
ich war jetzt nicht warst du bist ja ein
bisschen entspannen ich bleibe spannend
ich war nicht ganz einfach nur bock
drauf na ja auch so pleite ist man hier
und da mal ist man bleibt da muss man
auch mal rasseln und dann um wieder geld
zu haben
hast du gerade bei uns in berlin ist
öfter mal ist halt so aber wenn sie über
staatlich extrem verzweifelt oder so ich
hatte einfach mega bock drauf das ist
den ich machen brauche ich programm was
muss man für ansprüche erfüllen und
mitzumachen
es ist eigentlich nur soweit ich war
jetzt frei vor der kamera quatschen
können und er ist nicht schüchtern sein
du musst aber vor der kamera frei sein
du musst quatschen können
vielleicht für manche folgen ich habe
die ganze folge gar nicht gesehen leute
du weißt ja welche tausend sachen mehr
ich habe nur so passieren im kopf hat im
kopf viel mehr in diesem sondern damit
eine mutter hast wie du das ablecken ab
aber oberkörperfrei am kudamm
rumgelaufen habe ich kann ja ich bin da
frei auch unserem sehr ungenau
viele kommen nur in unterhose haben so
klein dass ich dachte okay das war schon
ein kleiner rtl2 haupt aber ich weiß
genau wie die tag und nacht bekommen ja
machen
die saison so habe ich genau zum indoor
mich wirst du immer noch oft erkannt
fragt keiner 2050 werde dadurch viele
viele formate ich bin jetzt aber erst
noch öfter mal kann weil ich das mache
also ja durch nicht nur direkt durch
hilft mir aber auch über die online
shops der grund für den terminator ich
hatte verschiedene formate auf
verschiedene leute das was hast du daran
und sie sagen ja die sagen ja auch nicht
immer herr ich kenne nicht davon oder
davon genau die sache viele sollte also
könig oder oder handschriftlich die auch
sehr korrekt war
da wäre ich auch mal kann auch erst
gestern abend wieder so eine linie fragt
inwiefern hat der dreh dein leben
beeinflusst also jetzt im negativen gar
nichts oder halt überhaupt dass mit ihr
zu rechnen ist aber quatsch er hat leute
darauf reagieren dass ich auf dem spitz
ich finde so abgehärtet was und
sachschaden so sind keine selbstironie
noch an jetzt ganz ehrlich wenn man aus
und japan würden der strom ist mit dem
oberkörper frei 70 prozent der baukosten
nur noch nichts
12 15 10 oder so keine ahnung also
negativ gar nicht positiv nun im sinne
von selbstironie und achtung man muss
auch selber drüberstehen können
viele leute sagen hast ja auch schon
gehabt
man muss ja wissen müsste man weiß ja
vorher was man macht irgendwie das ist
interessant das sehe ich bei dir und ich
glaube hier leute auch es ist wirklich
hat eine einstellungssache also leute
stehen einfach komplett unterschiedlich
dazu du bist wirklich absolut entspannt
dann wenn der nutzer unterwegs tja ich
weiß was ich gemacht habe
ich stehe halt drüber und air france
oder vielleicht war es auch bei dir
könnte ich mir vorstellen so ein
bisschen wir ja so eine gezwungene
entscheidung also meine und das ist von
anfang an klar gesagt okay das ist dass
das wird das und das verursache leute
mich ansprechen so aber du hast es von
anfang an zu durchschauen kriegt ja auch
das heißt dass man da rein gesetzt würde
sagen du machst das man kriegt ja ein
drehbuch zu verrückt man liest sich ja
alles durch und habe das gedreht habe
habe ich auch gelesen auch geht es war
eins zu eins das war ein fast eins zu
eins kam das kommt immer so kleine
kleine klitzekleine kleinigkeiten
ist hinüber trice und diesmal aber soll
nicht zu kleine unter die folge werde
ich sehen wo er meint dass man da
schlecht spielen muss extra und bei mir
jetzt nicht gesagt ob er in einem satz
spielen so und macht wieder wird das
spiel extra schlecht okay so gespielt
wie ich mich gefühlt hat vielleicht auf
eine volle verschieden weiß nicht recht
daran dass höhere andere teams ja ich
hatte eine sehr coole sneakers heute
noch kontakt mit der folge dass der
unfall die hoffen darauf dass heute
schon kontakt mit der einen frau die
ganze zeit dabei der revisor in das ist
auch gut also der gemeinsame freunde und
deswegen sei sie fragt musstest du
oberkörper frei herumlaufen war das
pflicht in der rolle
es war schon der große bestandteile
folge war schon daran das ist kein shirt
okay das muss es doch genauso waren auch
der dreh und hinter der kamera
das war schon also die pas team gab es
dann beschert aber es war eigentlich
schon sehr gern gesehen die rolle hätte
wahrscheinlich nicht funktioniert mit
mitte 30 oder mit sixpack und hätten den
sieg letztlich funktioniert das war
schon so natürlich brauchen klar und es
hat schon das war schon groß am stand
teil der check ist und dann kam mir die
haare noch dazu der vorderen gar nicht
geplant waren
das wird auch dachten es okay jetzt
haben wir jetzt haben wir das perfekte
laura fragt was war deine motivation
beihilfe mitzumachen außer geld rock
night ist einfach bock was auch so ich
will mich so ein bisschen in die
öffentlichkeit mal einfach das war schon
hart durch youtube beschäftigt ein
bisschen aktiv darunter ich wollte ins
fernsehen gehen und man dachte ich mir
ja klar das ein guter schritt eine
hauptrolle zu machen warum dich also ich
bin darauf entfernte sachen und so
machen doch mega spaß also es war schon
die ambition jetzt auch bis ins
fernsehen zu wehren so ok dann das so
quasi so als vielleicht den ersten step
das ist krass quartal also gerade szene
aber bleibt auch im kopf wenn man merkt
er weiß also kurze zwischenfrage von
johnny geht es dir gut und sind alle in
deinem umfeld gesund einfach mal gefragt
woher ich gute waren immer noch richtig
gut nur einmal wirklich ist auch in
mainz hieß von der yakult ja
möglicherweise ich bin gesund 22
zumindest alle umfeld sind cool also
alles super danke keine frage
johanna s t fragt inwiefern beeinflusst
die rolle oder beeinflusste die rolle
seine berufliche zukunft also das heißt
einerseits wie hat sich das entwickelt
aber wenn du jetzt den normalen job hast
ja und andererseits wie hat sich der
schauspielerei dadurch entwickelte sich
bereitwillig ja auch schon öfter war
angefragt haben durch weise einer
kartusche aktiv arbeitslosen 3
ausgestrahlt wird du hast ja einer karte
sehen da schon format und die leute
können das zwischen einen sehr nah liga
einzelnen frank zeit für andere sachen
anders da habe ich schon guter anfang
noch bekommen also das war positiv und
mein job ist ja auch positive also mein
chef hat es nicht gesehen aber wird ein
paar kollegen in zwei kollegen aber gar
nicht negative ist also alles oder so
dass man sagt das volk befragt musstest
du extra für die serie ungepflegt sein
also abzuwarten
also doch also ich kaufe jetzt du siehst
du so unterwegs vor allem die heimischen
so kostüm angezogen die halt nicht so
top sachen sind auf jeden fall vom
klamotten her und dann ja es war auch
ich habe es im hochsommer gedreht das
habe ich noch wärmer als heute sollen
bestimmt 30 33 34 geschlagen oder
schwitzt man halt auch und die haben wir
halt kein make-up kostüm da die sich
dann immer frisch machen wenn man halt
schwitzen da dreht sich alles um
vorteile aus also bewusst in kauf
genommen auf jeden also sie haben nichts
unternommen um ich gepflegt aussehen
kann als keine mega matthias augenhöhe
uns im gegenteil vielleicht sogar doch
noch einmal über den verteidiger der
marseiller könnte zum beispiel erzählt
dass ihm irgendwie seine härteste
geschminkt wurde so erst wieder rast
okay das ist bei mir nicht das nicht
also die haben nämlich nicht
verschandelt lädt das auch nicht
authentisch im sommer halten wie gesagt
meine hamburg 12 stunden am tag gedreht
oder sowie das drei tage am stück nach
was am wochenende und dann ist halt wenn
du hast außendrehs bei krummen 30 grad
reinheitsgrad alles hautnah
der schweizer hat den ganzen tag oder
ist halt so macht schon bisschen anders
aus zum abschluss vielleicht hast du
dich in der rolle des königs wohl
gefühlt
und ja ich muss echt sagen ja also ich
hab jetzt schon school
ja ich kann es mir ja lustig kann als
nichts negatives sagen also leute mega
interessante perspektive heute das mal
zu hören auch mal jemanden zu sehen der
die ganze sache komplett anders sieht
als dies bisher gemacht haben also der
voll dazu steht und das ist auch für
einen bock drauf hatte und nicht nur
wegen des geldes und easy money sondern
einfach ein bisschen action machen dinge
gefragt ja mich auch leute wie gesagt
erst in der beschreibung verlinkt ich
finde jetzt hier dringt noch einfach ich
vorgeschlagen könnte mein carbon wir
sehen uns dem neuen video